training teenagers to become more
self-aware she's using a game of cards
to start discussions about choice and
consent the larger goal is to empower
rural women
calcium Villages are less aware so we
encourage them to tell their parents
that they want to study or start working
before getting married everybody wants
children but they need to be independent
before that
India is home to 1.4 billion people this
population is projected to soon become
the world's largest it's expected to
Peak around 2016 and then start
declining
government data shows Indian women are
having fewer children it correlates this
with improvements in girls education
while Family Planning policies focus on
breaking taboos around contraception and
increasing awareness about maternal
Health
Community Health workers are providing
pre and postnatal Care chandrakala
advises new moms on breastfeeding
vaccinations and nutrition rural areas
have strong patriarchal Norms about
marriage and childbirth she says
families were earlier uncomfortable with
their work
there has been a major Awakening in the
village since we started working earlier
mothers would have had a second child
even when their first child was very
young or they would have become mothers
at a very young age that's become less
common
there are concerns about India's ability
to create jobs and feed people some
experts say a growing population could
be an advantage if the government
invests in creating jobs and improving
health care if you don't have all that
it leads to make you know diminishing
returns in terms of the economy but
it'll lead to social strife and
frustration you can't have an unhappy
large 350 million is our youth
population
Puja hopes her message will travel
Beyond this group and help more young
girls become independent experts say
this will help make family planning a
matter of choice and not chance
Rajasthan Western India